a very disturbing bullying incident on a
school bus caught on video raises
troubling questions about how the driver
and the school district handled this
incident the video shows a little Texas
five-year-old girl being attacked by
other kids now the driver appears to do
nothing despite pleas from this little
girl as Omar Villafranca reports her mom
now once the driver fired the disturbing
video shows five-year-old Alexis
Billings getting assaulted by not one
but two bigger kids on a Dallas school
bus at multiple points during the attack
she called out for help but help never
came
I couldn't believe what I saw Alexis's
mother Audrey Billings says she is angry
the bus driver did not help the little
girl I couldn't believe that there was
an adult there that could have stopped
it he does nothing the five year olds
mother says she requested the video
after the girl told her two boys hit her
before the mom posted it online she says
she had to pay the school district $600
for a copy the incident happened last
November as the children were leaving
school in the video you can see Billings
daughter is seated a couple rows behind
the unidentified bus driver as she yells
for his help the driver did ask the
other child to stop but never physically
intervene
the mother says during the attack alexis
was stabbed with the pencil choked and
elbowed in the neck in all the abuse
lasted about 12 minutes
the driver was removed from that bus
route but Billings is demanding he be
fired he should not be driving children
he needs to be removed from that
position 100% the Dallas Independent
School District issued a statement
saying they've taken steps to ensure
student safety including more training
and monitoring according to a 2017
government study about one in four US
students say they have been bullied
Billings says her daughter no longer
takes the bus and she hopes what
happened to her daughter doesn't happen
to other children this is my one chance
to make a change and I need to make sure
that I take advantage of that for CBS
this morning
Omar Villafranca Dallas thanks to that
mother for speaking up listen it's not
even my child and it's tough watching
that why wouldn't you just pull over get
out of your seat and stop that yeah well
you need a standard to be in place
you